[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 14 septembre
édition spéciale sur tv 60,18 largement
consacré à l'obtention des jeux
olympiques 2000 24 à paris au sommaire
de cette édition l'annoncent depuis lima
au pérou
hier suivi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'enceinte
sportive organisée une journée spéciale
autour des jo qui s'est terminée en fait
après l'officialisation de la nouvelle
aux alentours de 20 heures des jeux
olympiques 2024 et qui seront pleinement
vécue dans le département quatre sites
rien qu'à saint quentin en yvelines
devrait accueillir est des épreuves dont
le vélodrome
réactions dans ce journal de sportive
d'élus mais aussi d'habitants du
territoire
enfin pour parler des yvelines au coeur
du projet olympique nous recevons sur ce
plateau deux invités gerald de favier
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines en charge de la communication
et des grands événements internationaux
et jean marc trénel délégué aux sports à
la ville de versailles
et puis le reste de l'actualité
yvelinoise bien sûr à suivre également
en fin de journal on accueille tout de
suite nos deux invités sur ce plateau je
les dis à gerald de favier vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
en charge de la communication et des
grands événements internationaux ainsi
que jean-marc fresnel délégué aux sports
à la ville de versailles bonsoir
messieurs vous allez nous accompagner
tout au long de cette édition spéciale
alors paris aura bien les jo en 2024
décision officialisée hier par le comité
international olympique depuis lima au
pérou
au lendemain de cette annonce comment
les saint quentinois accueille-t-il
cette nouvelle micro tendu par patrick
jacques de dixmude et axel bébel bah ça
fait ça fait longtemps qu'on n'avait pas
eu les jeux olympiques donc bon c'est
une bonne chose ça va tirer du monde ça
va peut-être créer de l'emploi
c'est une très bonne vitrine
la po paris on ne peut pas dire que
c'est quelque chose de négatif
et pour cinq ans avec le jeu mais c'est
super ils n'ont connu pour sa très
quelconque que ça m'intéresse pas
tellement mais je trouve que c'est pas
mal qu'on les joue à paris le seul truc
qui me préoccupe un peu quand même cédé
financement qu'on voit tous les
financements depuis quelques années on
est toujours en déplacement mais et ça a
tout le monde a l'air de trouver
conseils financiers
moi je suis prêt à écouter je n'étais
même pas au courant je n'ai entendu
voilà donc qui charrie ça va amener la
gaieté pour les gens ça va mener le
travail ça va ramer
l'événement sportif est un peu de joie
chez eux devant la france qu'on va dire
le verdict a été révélé de l'autre côté
de l'atlantique mais vécue aussi en
direct depuis le vélodrome de saint
quentin en yvelines le futur site
olympique organisait une journée puis
une soirée spéciale à l'occasion de
l'attribution des jo plus de 500
personnes présentes et on s'y attendait
l'événement s'est conclue sur une note
festive
patrick jacques de dixmude et michael
mier doro étaient sur place
la fièvre olympique s'est propagée dans
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce mercredi 13
septembre plus de 500 supporters
tricolores sont venus assister en direct
à la danse du cio via des écrans géants
installés pour l'occasion
bah oui c'est important ça fait cent ans
que paris attend les jo donc je pense
que c'est important de célébrer tous
ensemble cet événement aujourd'hui être
présent
pour cette première échéance je dirais
de confirmation de gillot oui c'est
important on est acteur tous autant
qu'on est à chaque niveau donc oui pour
faire entendre ses fans jusqu'à
l'annoncé officielle des animations
sportives étaient organisées sur place
le rider de l'équipe de france jérémy
rencurel qualifiés pour les derniers
jeux olympiques à rio l'été dernier en a
profité pour faire des démonstrations
avec des enfants devant le public
c'est important parce que ça ça pousse
il a fait découvrir aussi le baby c'est
par un sport très médiatisée notamment
la piste est peut-être un peu plus et du
coup bah ça fait connaître notre sport
après de longues minutes d'attentes le
verdict tombe enfin paris officiellement
désignée ville hôte pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024 par le film
une réaction extraordinaire une réaction
de joie une réaction de joie
les jeux olympiques sont à paris en 2024
c'est officiellement officiel maintenant
et là c'est vraiment une explosion de
joie on a senti lors de l' annonce est
maintenant l aventure commence une
aventure commence est une aventure
historique et ça va être passionnant de
vivre cette période
les supporters présents vélodrome
national espère maintenant vibrer dans
un peu moins de 7 ans avec des médailles
d'or françaises
et pour parler de cette actualité
olympique je rappelle que nous avons
avec nous en plateau deux invités jean
marc fresnel délégué du maire de
versailles en charge des sports est
également gerald de favier vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
en charge à des grands événements
internationaux et de la communication
c'est ans nous séparent désormais des
jeux olympiques à paris événement
planétaire qui fuyaient la capitale
depuis un siècle et ils sont directement
concernés par l'obtention de segi hausse
et les sportifs français réaction
collecter hier au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
pour moi c'est un peu sans surprise
parce que vraiment on a mis toutes nos
chances de notre côté voilà c'était
beaucoup au reggae sur les réseaux
sociaux et tout donc très contente
ça faisait longtemps qu'on les a pas
eues c'est taylor d'avoir on n'est pas
passé loin à londres on n'est pas passé
loin avant on appose présenté plusieurs
candidatures de temps en temps qui
étaient pas bonnes d'autres étaient
bonnes et puis à londres ça nous a fait
mal et là on sait on a vraiment mis les
moyens et je pense que la candidature
était la plus belle et c'était normal
que paris et les jeux en 2024
un soulagement un soulagement et un an
dans l'ensemble de joie satisfait
contente et pelé dia les gigots
prendront part dans le département des
épreuves devraient se dérouler à saint
quentin en yvelines vous le verrez dans
un instant par un sujet proposé par
notre rédaction par notre rédaction par
dont justement pour parler de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines je vous
propose d'écouter une réaction celle de
michel laugier président de
l'agglomération
on aurait pu développer toute la
communication que nous voulions
jamais on n'aurait pu toucher le monde
entier comme l'avs c'est le cas en ce
moment
les chefs d'entreprise que j'ai
rencontres sont aussi hyper motivés
vendée quant à corps d'yves en parler
avec leurs homologues à l'étranger
ils vont parler bien sûr comme référence
donnée comme lieu de référence un
territoire olympique
et puis aussi d'un an de vie de 24
lorsque tous les sportifs se rend l'air
lorsque les spectateurs seront là
d'ailleurs aussi toutes les retombées
économiques et je me tourne vers nos
deux invités d'abord gerald de favier
vice-présidente
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillir ces
jeux à paris et donc à saint quentin en
yvelines parce que voilà on l'a dit à
des épreuves se dérouleront sur le
territoire
est ce que c'est quelque chose oui
d'extraordinaire pour la notoriété de
l'agglomération c'est absolument
fantastique au sens que bien évidemment
on en parle depuis très longtemps déjà
en 2012 nous avions été frustré d'être
passé à côté et il va de soi que
50 à un suivi et participer activement
je dirai à la promotion de cette
candidature
c'est très important pour notre
territoire car incontestablement ça va
donner un coup de boost est
extraordinaire à la fois à tout le monde
associatif et sportif mais également sur
plan économique on en parlera dans un
instant mais par le fait même que un
événement planétaire comme celui ci bien
évidemment heureux à des retombées dans
tous les domaines et nous espérons bien
sûr il ya saint quentin en yvelines
on en profitera un au maximum jean-marc
révèle côté versailles qui jouit déjà
d'une notoriété internationale de par
son château
par exemple le fait de recevoir ces
épreuves on parle ici de l'équitation du
cyclisme sur route notamment quels
bénéfices supplémentaires cela va
apporter à versailles
on parle du gué du pentathlon c'est le
papa se gagnent dans l'oubli souvent le
pas 4e et où c'est une très belle
épreuve
évidemment versailles
à sa propre notoriété liés au château
donc c'est aussi une des raisons pour
laquelle les le site a été choisi mais
je pense que derrière il ya autre chose
ça y est beaucoup plus que le
l'événement en lui-même il ya toute la
dynamique qui va être mise en place
j'espère entre maintenant et les jeux
par l'ensemble des structures sportives
fédéral et c est le ministère et il faut
s'asseoir impulsé très haut il faut que
nos jeunes aujourd'hui vous le disiez au
début ce qui ont 14 ans aujourd'hui
auront 21 22 ans dans sept ans et eux
ils sont en plein dans les jeux fab est
jouée une émulation ah oui et il faut qu
si on adapte nos structures on adapte
nos organisations on fasse en sorte que
le sport devienne une priorité
importante dans la pratique et puis
prenez l'exemple de londres les anglais
ont plus une culture du sport que nous
ils ont eu les jeux donc ça a fonctionné
ils ont été je crois les deuxièmes pays
en nombre de médailles
lorsque les jeux étaient chez eux
regardez ce qui s'est passé c'est cet
été les championnats du monde
d'athlétisme en 2017 cinq ans après le
stade était plein tous les jours y
compris le matin parce que la dynamique
sportive et elle marche elle fonctionne
et c'est des gens de compétences en
faire ils sont chauvins comme tous les
publics
ils applaudissent plus fortement leurs
athlètes que les autres mais derrière
ils connaissent bien le monde du sport
etc
donc je pense que cette il faut que les
jeux olympiques nous donne c'est un peu
un feu d'artifice qui démarque certes
les belles les belles les belles fusée
qui éclate mais derrière il ya tout ce
qu'on va en tirer pour nous et à nous
aussi bien sur les collectivités de
prendre part à cela et faire en sorte
que enfin au moins c'est ma conviction
les enfants il faut qu'ils fassent du
sport parce qu'il faut que notre société
face du sport est bien plus demain que
qu'elle ne le fait aujourd'hui
l'émulation sportive retombées en terme
d'image si on parle des des retombées
économiques qui évoquait monsieur favier
il ya un instant pour pour versailles
est ce qu on a une idée de ce que ça
pourrait rapporter ces jo non ça va
envoyer c'est dans cette rsa a été
mesurée choix d'une manière générale je
crois que
de 10 milliards de recettes parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de dépenses on oublie
aussi les recettes les gens viennent
voir les jeux les sportifs ou les
spectateurs qui viennent du pays de tous
les pays viennent voir les jeux qui
reste et donc qu'ils consomment dans une
même si nos châteaux il ya beaucoup de
monde mais c'est peut-être pas forcément
des gens qui vont rester plusieurs jours
sur le site
et puis je crois dit le déjà le comité
d'organisation enfin tout ce qu'on a dit
sur la dynamique sportive
ça aussi c'est des emplois ça aussi
c'est ddt structure qu'il faut mettre en
place
et puis tout autour la dynamique sur les
transports la dynamique sur les
économies à l'énergie durable fas tout
ça c'est des choses qui peuvent se
mettre en place
grâce au jeu où tous - qui sont selon
s'accélérer grâce à la présence des jeux
le département va accueillir on l'a dit
plusieurs épreuves de ces jeux
olympiques 2024 pour saint quentin en
yvelines
quatre sites ont été retenus dans le
dossier de candidature notamment le golf
national à guyancourt opportunité
exceptionnelle pour la discipline du
golf en france devenue olympique
je vous le rappelle lors des jo de rio
l'an passé je vous propose d'écouter à
ce sujet paul hermitage directeur du
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est une opportunité pour le golf
français parce que on va s'adresser à un
tout autre public par exemple la ryder
cup est importante
il y aura un héritage ryder cup les cent
petites structures le développement du
golf en france
mais les jo vont nous apporter
certainement du golfe mainstream sur la
télévision nationale
beaucoup plus de visibilité dans les
médias autour du golf donc ça c'est
important
trois autres sites seront situés à saint
quentin en yvelines le vélodrome
nationale la colline d'elancourt et
l'île de loisirs récapitulatif avec
notre journaliste sportif ni talent et
demi d'euros saint quentin en yvelines
sera l'honneur pendant les jo de 2024
quatre sites ont été retenus par les
organisateurs français les épreuves de
cyclisme sur piste seront programmés
dans le vélodrome nationale la structure
inaugure en 2014 a déjà accueilli les
championnats du monde en 2015 et les
championnats d'europe l'année suivante
bien sûr ça à lèves le doute sur sur
toutes les interrogations qu'on pourrait
avoir un la l'équipement il est là il a
été testé il a accueilli déjà la plus
grandes échéances internationales avec
les championnats du monde donc je pense
que tout ça c'est forcément des
garanties pour le seuil haut à une
centaine de mètres du vélodrome lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines a
été sélectionné dans le dossier paris
2024 pour accueillir les épreuves
masculines et féminines de bmx une piste
modulable sera construite sur ce terrain
vague de sept hectares
ce site a été choisi principalement
parce qu'ils jour je te le vélodrome on
est on est à 100 mètres à pied du
vélodrome
donc il y aura une parfaite
complémentarité entre les épreuves qui
se dérouleront dans le vélodrome et les
épreuves de bmx ici sans parler du cadre
nature qui s'y prête parfaitement la
colline d'elancourt accueillera quant à
elle les épreuves de vtt le projet dans
les cartons depuis les jo de 2012 a été
ressortie pour la candidature de paris
2024 le site qui culmine à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude fait toujours autant
l'unanimité auprès des organisateurs
pour accueillir les épreuves de vtt
la première force et l'unité de lieu le
deuxième point là ici c'est la
dénivellation et donc le vtt on appelle
ça mountain bike c'est du vélo de
montagne et donc il faut aller chercher
à des pentes raides et il ya quasiment
qu'ici qu'on a qu'on a ce que l'on
souhaite pour avoir quelque chose de
très raide
donc oui c'est assez naturel que ça
vienne ici sur la sur la colline de la
revanche
enfin le golf national recevrait les
épreuves golfique les joueurs
disputeront les parties sur le parcours
de l'albatros le 18 trous
réputé comme l'un des plus compliqués au
monde a été entièrement rénové
1015 et 2016 ce challenge ali de plus
c'est une super compétition et dans les
cadres se voiler
les jo les gones nationale serait le
premier parcours de golf du monde en
dresser wayne ryder cup est légion donc
assez quand même et non ça fait pas peur
c'est simplet mehmood shah l'un des plus
à sa savante d'émotion à la vie dans le
reste des yvelines les épreuves
d'équitation de pentathlon moderne se
disputeront à versailles les courses de
cyclisme sur route devrait quant à elle
passer dans la vallée de chevreuse pour
saint quentin en yvelines il reste donc
deux sites à faire il faut aménager est
la colline d'elancourt pour le vtt avec
une zone d'accueil du public une zone
d'accueil de presse est également le
parking un stadium de bmx également pour
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
jarle de favier qu'elle va être là
qu'elle va être parent dont le
calendrier qui sera mis en place
quelles sont les priorités déjà alors il
est clair que ce calendrier c'est pas
nous qui le maîtrise on s'est davantage
mais c'est de la responsabilité du
comité d'organisation qui va se mettre
en place dans les tout prochains jours
mais il va de soi que si l'on prend par
exemple le circuit devait été sur la
colline d'elancourt il faudra
nécessairement que les installations
soient prêtes au moins une bonne année
voire deux ans avant 2024 de façon à ce
que les le parcours soit testée par des
épreuves
qui de niveau national et même
international avant bien évidemment
l'organisation des jeux par eux mêmes la
grande difficulté sur cette mise en
oeuvre c'est surtout de permettre aux
télévisions de pouvoir véritablement
capter toutes les images or la colline
d'elancourt est aujourd'hui vraiment un
site que nous apprécions et que nous
voulons préserver son plan de la nature
je dirais toute la partie arborée on
voudrait pas qu'un soit je dirais à
devienne un désert et ça va être une
discussion entre les biens sur les
considérations sportives mais également
les choix qui sont les nôtres de
préserver cette colline pour permettre
aux familles de pouvoir bien évidemment
en bénéficier et permettre à tous les
sportifs de l'utiliser bien au delà même
des jeux olympiques
est-ce qu'on est face à une idée du coût
global pour aménager par exemple cette
colline puisque saint quentin en
yvelines devra payer quelque chose il y
aura des subventions aussi parties la
partie sportive des les pistes de
compétition sont du ressort du comité
olympique comme l'est par exemple
l'installation éphémère du bmx sur l'île
de loisirs donc tout cela cette partie
sera pris en compte par le cio mais nous
aurons bien évidemment tout un
environnement dans lesquels nous avons
des exigences entre autres pour ce que
je viens de vous exprimer et faire en
sorte que cette colline qui est en place
depuis des décennies mais qui
malheureusement n'est pas hésité comme
nous traiterions devienne véritablement
un lieu attractif pour l'ensemble des
saint quentinois et bien et même au delà
qu'on peut l'être bien sûr et reste de
dire un mot très rapide ce qui nous
reste une minute le temps file sur la
ligne 18 ans est un projet qui est prévu
pour 2030 l'alleud la priorité c'est
l'avancé à 2024 il faut la lui que
l'émission arrive à versailles ayant
cours en 2024
pardonnez moi nous sommes vent debout je
parle les élus de saint quentin en
yvelines sur cette annonce qui a été
faite effectivement de reporter la ligne
18 la partie qui nous intéresse la
partie yvelinoise et les élus de saint
quentin en yvelines qui étaient réunis
cet après midi je parle de tous les
maires vont bien évidemment se
mobilisent et se mobilisaient pour faire
en sorte que cette décision soit revue
et que la ligne 18 soit en place pour
les jeux olympiques nous en avons besoin
c'est un impératif même priorité
versailles et où les ai vus sur les élus
des yvelines qui se mobilisent là dessus
sur il se hissera impensable aujourd'hui
de penser qu'un projet de métro dauphin
de ligne 18 puis 7 reculé alors qu'on a
les jeux qui sont en 2024
c'est même pas 2025 il faudrait que
south est 2023 2023 2024
et puis je les aime à s'appeler une
compte petit contraire à ce qu'on le
fait que mon âme cyclisme les bases nous
on va les chevreuse mais avec des
passages dans versailles et peut-être
des choses intéressante à versailles le
cyclisme c'est le seul sport qui soit
gratuit pour le public et donc je pense
que là aussi on a on aura à faire
beaucoup plus d'ailleurs à permettre aux
habitants de nos régions de venir et
d'être présent sur des événements comme
ça comme l'est le tour de france parce
que ça se passe devant chez eux ou dans
chez eux dans la rue et là c'est gratuit
alors que bon quand il faudra aller au
château pour voir un concours hippique
c'est un peu plus compliqué par
compliqué mais il faut payer
merci à nos deux invités d'être
intervenu sur ce plateau je rappelle
gerald favier vice-présidente saint
quentin en yvelines en charge des grands
événements internationaux et de la
communication et jean-marc fresnel
délégué du maire de versailles en charge
des sports merci à vous deux sports
culture humanitaire ou encore loisirs le
choix et les activités sont variées pour
les vingt mille étudiants de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
associations étudiantes étaient réunis
cet après midi sur le campus de
guyancourt reportage de nicolas
kirillovitch échanger rencontrer et
expliqué c'était l'heure de la rentrée
pour les différentes associations de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
un premier rendez vous avec les
étudiants et une prise de contact pour
encourager les entrants à s'investir
dans la vie du campus les étudiants ils
se rendent pas forcément compte que
maintenant on est plus au lycée
maintenant on est
à la fac il ya des associations pour
qu'il fasse plein de connaissances
surtout avec des étudiants de des
différentes promotions
moi j'ai beaucoup d'amis que je garde
très précieusement encore aujourd'hui
notamment à travers l'associatif mais
pas que et voilà c'est une expérience
quoi on vit ici et ça fait partie de la
vie une vie associative qui se développe
progressivement à lui vs qu 25 ans après
sa création l'université compte
désormais plus de 30 associations
actives sur ses différents sites
les associations sont là pour réaliser
des événements culturels mais aussi
créer des liens animé c'est surtout
aussi pour animer les campus rien que
sur saint quentin le territoire de saint
quentin on a douze associations qui sont
vraiment présente présent les étudiants
de l'éts et aussi comme issa qui reprend
cette année ses études d'hôtellerie et
de tourisme entre les études et le
travail la jeune femme espère ainsi
trouver une occupation pour se changer
les idées
il ya beaucoup de choses il ya des
multitudes de choses qu'on peut faire
mais ce qui m'a intéressé surtout c 'est
le jardin partagé également le théâtre
pourquoi pas autre chose j'ai pas tout
fini je vais peut faire le tour d'autres
forums associatifs sont prévues pour
répondre aux attentes des vingt mille
étudiants de l'ue vs q prochain rendez
vous le jeudi 28 septembre sur le campus
de versailles avec plus de 550 mille
hectares de terres agricoles d'île de
france est aussi une région à
d'agriculture pensée oubliée n'oubliez
pas que ligne à la beauce qui est
véritable grenier un véritable grenier
avec blaise est beau ce un bien sûr
s'étend sur une partie du sud de l'île
de france c'est pour mettre en valeur
les saveurs et les produits du terroir
qui est organisée elle les semaines du
manger local en ile de france c'est du
16 septembre au 8 octobre et pour
présenter ces semaines avec leur plateau
jean claude guénin qui m'ont soir
bonsoir
vous êtes le premier vice président du
service à paris ile de france et le
centre régional de valorisation et
d'innovation alimentaires et agricoles
je précise également que vous êtes
maraîchers dans les yvelines
pourquoi cet événement est il nécessaire
pour quoi valoriser finalement ce
terroir francilien ben je crois que
c'est très simple les parisiens et les
consommateurs d'ile-de-france pense qui
a pas de production agricole mais autour
de paris il ya énormément de production
agricole serait qu'on peut penser à tort
que quand on parle terroir agriculture
on va penser d'abord à la province -
l'ile-de-france mais l'île de france
mais c'est une véritable région
d'agriculture il ya cent cinquante mille
hectares de basse et la moitié du
territoire
un coup la moitié du territoire alors
c'est vrai qu'on parle de la bouse mais
autour de la ceinture verte est allé
pour les premiers c'est les producteurs
de fruits et légumes
et puis après il ya les céréales mais
avec des céréales et bien on peut faire
des biscuits je pense notamment à les
deux gourmands qui soit rue pierre ces
deux jeunes qui se sont installés donc
il présente le servir les accompagner et
donc ça permet de lier la production
mais aussi la transformation et est
également les intermédiaires c'est à
dire les magasins et ça plaît aussi aux
boulangers aux détaillants à tout ce qui
va dans la consommation des produits
locaux
en plus de nombreux produits qu'on
connaît le pain forcément avec le blé
quillan la beauce le cresson le fromage
aussi à plein de plein de choses
multitude de produits en ile de france
il ya vraiment de tout donc que le
cervia nous permet de confronter toutes
les filières gé du producteur aux
transformateurs et je dirais aux
commerçants au sens large est de mettre
tout le monde ensemble pour justement
dire qu'il existe des produits elles
devront qui sont à notre portée et c'est
pour cette raison-là compte
avons créé la semaine mangeons local
pour que les consommateurs parisiens
puissent pour voir acheter ses produits
et se faire connaître et donc non pas
une mais des semaines du monde local
puisque trois semaines vont se dérouler
pendant trois semaines c'est ces
semaines du coup nous mangeons local
quelles vont être les grands les grands
temps forts ou et de l'événement en est
déjà le premier le lancement c'est le
samedi avec le marché à la porte de
clignancourt avec un marché de
producteurs
il ya onze producteurs qui vont être
présents donc pour vous justement lancé
il ya sa mort est également le feu ce
troc
après il ya les jardins ouverts et puis
bien sûr il ya également des visites de
fermes on se déroule sur trois semaines
donc il ya des activités tout le temps
et de toute façon tous les participants
il ya 500 professionnels qui
participants ils sont estampillés
mangeons local
donc ça va du boulanger mais au boucher
aux producteurs aux détaillants et même
aussi la restauration collective qu'il
faut pas oublier on précise d'ailleurs
avec des établissements yvelinois
participent à l'opération notamment la
boulangerie de la fuite à montigny le
bretonneux ainsi que les fermes de gally
à saint-cyr-l'ecole bien d'autres encore
dark et les deux gourmands et les deux
grands qui sont des jeunes performants
qui sont issus pour un des deux associés
du monde agricole
leurs parents ou une ferme et justement
pour transformer les produits et dans la
plaine de versailles très rapidement
jean claude gannac dernière question en
quoi ça serait une réussite c'est
semaine quel est l'objectif finalement
derrière à la fin de ces semaines
l'objectif c'est que les consommateurs
puissent acheter des produits de
proximité
nous sommes la première zone j'aurais
agricoles autour de paris et ses
semaines dumange local je rappelle les
dates c'est du 16 septembre au 8 octobre
le programme complet de l'événement est
apte à retrouver sur le site internet de
l'événement et qui s'affiche en bas et
donc je remercie mon invité jean-claude
guennec premier vice-président du cervia
paris ile de france merci d'avoir été
avec nous merci avant de se quitter
fabriquer votre propre savons c est ce
que propose l'association et jardins
passions partage ce samedi 16 septembre
à 14 heures à guyancourt
atelier animé par un artisan de fabrique
un fabricant de savons et savonnerie et
labellisé nature époque et progresser
savons sont donc naturel et bio
gic et surtout fabriqués à base de miel
le miel est un agent hydratant
c'est d'abord c'est bon pour le corps
mes parents et apiculteurs j'ai été
élevé avec les abeilles le miel est pour
moi y est naturel d'avoir du miel dans
un produit de soins quotidiens comme le
savon je ferai devant tous les
participants en allant bien doucement
chacun en expliquant bien chacune des
étapes
et puis les chaque participant pourra
refaire chez lui ma la même chose c'est
la fin de cette édition spéciale jo-2000
24 à paris elle est à retrouver en
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv
78e bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
nous